[Musique]
a rendez-vous avec une centaine
d'environnementalistes pour manifester
devant la centrale nucléaire de Tihange
en Belgique les choses commencent enfin
à évoluer et il était temps parce qu'on
a produit le car de l'électricité en
Belgique mais plus pour longtemps l'un
de ces trois réacteurs le réacteur
numéro 2 va bientôt produire ses
derniers kilowatt-heure après 40 ans de
service
dans quelques heures les opérateurs de
la centrale nucléaire qui est derrière
moi vont commencer à réduire
progressivement la puissance du réacteur
petit à petit jusqu'à finalement
l'arrêter tout à fait
pour les manifestants la fermeture de
Tihange 2 est une erreur une énorme
erreur aujourd'hui étant donné les
enjeux que l'on a confronté il n'y a pas
de plus grandes erreur que de fermer un
outil qui fonctionne et qui nous aide
contre tous les enjeux auxquels on est
confronté
[Musique]
Émile Jacobs est venu des Pays-Bas
en 2017 il avait manifesté pour la
fermeture de la centrale
c'est le deuxième réacteur nucléaire
belge assez de produire de l'électricité
depuis septembre 2022
chaque fermeture augmente le recours aux
énergies fossiles et du même coup les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre quand
on arrête une centrale nucléaire elle
doit être compensée par autre chose en
Belgique on a des centrales à gaz elle
va être compensée directement par des
centrales à gaz
la décision de sortir du nucléaire a été
prise en Belgique il y a 20 ans à
l'époque l'énergie atomique faisait
craindre le pire mais aujourd'hui dans
le contexte des changements climatiques
et de la crise énergétique en Europe des
environnementsalistes et des
gouvernements veulent faire marche
arrière
ça fait plusieurs années que je me
questionne sur les vertus de l'énergie
nucléaire
adolescente je rêvais de sauver la
planète
j'ai fait mes études d'ingénieur en
environnement pour aider à protéger les
lacs et les rivières
aujourd'hui je suis journaliste et c'est
le réchauffement climatique qui
m'inquiète
la température moyenne de la planète
pourrait augmenter de 4 degrés d'ici
les événements climatiques violents se
multiplient les glaciers fondent plus
vite que jamais
et une bonne partie de la population
mondiale est menacée par les déviations
du niveau de la mer
si on veut éviter le pire les émissions
mondiales de CO2 devraient tomber à zéro
d'ici 2050
ça c'est selon le Groupe d'experts
intergouvernemental sur l'évolution du
climat le chien
pour les militants crousnucléaires la
solution existe depuis 70 ans
c'est l'énergie atomique
j'aimerais savoir si l'énergie nucléaire
est vraiment verte ou si elle est trop
isquée et trop coûteux
j'ai décidé d'aller à la rencontre
d'environnementaliste pro-nucléaire en
Europe et au Canada
je veux entendre leurs arguments
ici en Ontario on s'est débarrassé du
charbon comment on a fait ça on a fait
grâce au nucléaire
il a lancé une pétition pour que le
gouvernement de l'Ontario prolonge
l'activité de la centrale nucléaire de
Pickering dont l'arrêt est prévue pour
pour moi c'était une évidence
en Finlande j'ai rencontré
une organisation connue pour ses actions
antinucléaires partout dans le monde
revoit ses positions
[Musique]
ce monument représentait l'égoïsme
Greenpeace la construit en 2010 pour
dénoncer les membres du Parlement qui
avaient voté en faveur d'un projet
nucléaire
le monument est régulièrement vandalisé
quelqu'un a écrit vive l'énergie
nucléaire Greenpeace a dit que si
c'était à refaire elle ne construirait
pas ce monument
en France aussi le nucléaire revient en
grâce
des pays les plus nucléarisés au monde
70% de l'électricité des Français
provient de la fission atomique
inventons les technologies les progrès
de demain François Hollande l'ancien
président avait promis de fermer des
réacteurs nucléaires lors de sa campagne
électorale de 2012 mais en 2022 le
gouvernement fait volte face Emmanuel
Macron demande la construction de six
nouveaux réacteurs je souhaite qu'aucun
réacteur nucléaire en état de produire
ne soit fermé à l'avenir
il faut que le nucléaire arrive est dès
que possible et même s'il arrive en 2035
en 2040 en 2045 chaque centrale
nucléaire qui arrive c'est des centrales
fossiles qui ferment c'est nous nous
sommes parmi vous Myrto tripathie a
fondé les voies du nucléaire
c'est une association citoyenne en
France qui fait la promotion de
l'énergie nucléaire pour lutter contre
les changements climatiques
je l'ai retrouvé en banlieue de Paris
comme moi elle est ingénieur de
formation
elle a travaillé 10 ans dans l'industrie
nucléaire avant de quitter son emploi
pour devenir militante c'est pas parce
que on travaille dans l'industrie
nucléaire qu'on peut pas nous faire
confiance c'est parce qu'on travaille
dans l'industrie nucléaire qu'on sait de
quoi on parle
[Musique]
les militants ont raison lorsqu'ils
disent que l'énergie nucléaire n'avait
pas de gaz à effet de serre
j'ai regardé les chiffres
[Musique]
le GIEC à comparer les émissions de
différentes sources d'énergie le charbon
arrive en tête pour chaque kilowattheure
d'électricité il envoie l'équivalent de
820 g de CO2 dans l'atmosphère le gaz
est deuxième avec 490 g par
kilowattheure le solaire c'est 10 fois
moins
l'hydroélectricité comme on a au Québec
fait encore mieux
le nucléaire lui est en bas de la liste
avec 12 g de CO2 pour chaque
kilowattheure
l'éolien arrive pratiquement avec ses
cours le deuxième argument des militants
comme Virtu tripathie c'est que
l'énergie nucléaire est capable de
produire de l'électricité en continu
les énergies éoliennes et solaire ont
présente des avantages celui de pouvoir
être déployé rapidement à peu près dans
n'importe quelle géographie
de décarboner des endroits isolés mais
par contre elles sont absolument pas
fiables dans leur production incapables
de produire en continu on emprunte
environnementale assez importante
ils aiment rappeler que l'éolien et le
solaire produisent de l'électricité
seulement quand ils vendent ou quand il
fait soleil
et quelle technologie de stockage
d'électricité à grande échelle ne sont
pas encore au point
l'éolien et elle brûle plus de charbon
que jamais
en 2011 juste après l'accident de
Fukushima Angela Merkel annonce la
fermeture des 17 réacteurs nucléaires de
l'Allemagne avant 2022
pour compenser le gouvernement investit
massivement dans les énergies
renouvelables surtout des projets
éoliens et solaires
pour faire la transition l'Allemagne
mise sur des centrales au gaz qui sont
moins émettrices de CO2 que le charbon
plus de la moitié du gaz qui arrive en
Allemagne provient de Russie
avec la guerre en Ukraine le robinet a
été coupé
en 2022 les trois dernières centrales
nucléaires en opération en Allemagne ont
été prolongées pour quelques mois
mais la production d'électricité par le
charbon est reparti à la hausse
si on ne veut pas de charbon et de gaz
et ben il faut regarder ce qui est
nucléaire quitte à s'accommoder de se
désavantages et elle est traitée et elle
les encadrer
tous les militants pro nucléaires que
j'ai rencontrés admettent que les
énergies solaires et éoliennes vont
jouer un rôle central pour réduire nos
émissions à zéro
seulement qu'elle ne pourront pas y
arriver toute seule
le mouvement anti-nucléaire dit le
contraire
en France ce mouvement est encore bien
vivant je vous suivrai pas sur ce
terrain là voilà au téléphone Myrto
tripathie tente de se faire inviter à un
débat public sur l'avenir du nucléaire
qui se tiendra dans quelques jours à
Lyon non pas du tout on a déjà eu des
interventions de Greenpeace qui
intervenait dans les débats et qui
empêchaient les débats de se dérouler la
bataille de Myrto tripatis n'est pas
gagné la route des pronucléaires
s'annonce mouvementée
attends j'ai 10 minutes là pour faire le
truc mirto tripathie vient tout juste
d'arriver à Lyon
débat public sur la place du nucléaire
dans le mix énergétique français
la présidente des voix du nucléaire
Satan a passé un moment difficile
les dernières séances du débat national
sur l'avenir du nucléaire en France ont
été houleuses
[Musique]
et ce soir ne fera pas exception
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
trop longtemps dans la tête de bien des
gens la fission nucléaire se résume en
un mot danger
on sait peu de choses encore du grave
accident nucléaire qui s'est produit à
la centrale de Tchernobyl juste au nord
de Kiev en Ukraine j'avais 14 ans quand
la catastrophe de Tchernobyl est arrivée
je me souviens de ne pas comprendre
grand chose mais d'avoir peur
le 26 avril 1986 le réacteur numéro 4 de
la centrale nucléaire de Tchernobyl dans
le nord de l'Ukraine explose
l'explosion et l'incendie qui s'ensuit
propulse de grandes quantités diode et
de césium radioactifs dans l'atmosphère
les impacts de l'accident ont été
largement étudiés par les scientifiques
du monde entier entre autres par un
comité de l'ONU qu'on appelle on scare
selon ces conclusions une trentaine de
personnes seraient morte dans les
semaines qui ont suivi l'accident parce
qu'elles ont été exposées à une dose de
radiation aiguë
plus tard 5000 autres personnes auraient
développé un cancer de la thyroïde
le taux de mortalité du cancer de la
thyroïde se situe entre deux et 8%. ça
veut dire entre 100 et 400 décès
[Musique]
les militantes nucléaires rendissent des
chiffres beaucoup plus élevés
certains par exemple parlent de 100 000
morts
qui sont produits par les centrales
nucléaires sans émettre de CO2 valent
beaucoup plus que le risque d'un
accident aussi spectaculaire soit-il
quand vous mettez pas en Balance le
risque avec le bénéfice mais même un
tout petit risque il sera trop un tout
petit risque à côté de rien c'est
forcément trop
petit risque
c'est surtout un risque qui n'a plus
lieu d'être c'est un risque qu'on a
maîtrisé c'est un risque qu'on a compris
c'est une situation qui n'arrivera plus
l'autre accident nucléaire qui a marqué
l'imaginaire c'est celui de Fukushima le
11 mars 2011
les autorités s'entendent pour dire que
personne n'est mort de la radiation
aiguë Fukushima un seul travailleur est
décédé d'un cancer 7 ans plus tard mais
des milliers de personnes seraient
décédées à cause du stress provoqué par
l'évacuation
elles sont magnifiques c'est tout c'est
extraordinaire
Emmanuel Galichet et professeur de génie
nucléaire au Conservatoire national des
arts et métiers le Cnam à Paris pour
elle une centrale nucléaire c'est une
merveille technologique la fumée qui
sort des tours ça fait peur à certaines
personnes oui ça fait peur mais en fait
c'est que de la vapeur d'eau donc c'est
absolument pas de la pollution ça permet
de refroidir le circuit secondaire qui
est là pour justement
actionner la turbine et faire de
l'électricité je suis allée avec
Emmanuel Galichet à Nogent-sur-Seine à
100 km de Paris
je veux savoir comment la sûreté
nucléaire a évolué depuis les accidents
de Tchernobyl et de Fukushima en France
il est absolument impossible qu'il y ait
un accident tel que on a vu à Tchernobyl
ou à Fukushima ça veut pas dire qu'il
peut pas y avoir d'accident à le risque
zéro n'existe pas les ingénieurs formés
par Emmanuel Galichet conçoivent ce
qu'on appelle des systèmes de défense en
profondeur pour éviter les accidents
c'est à dire que vous allez mettre plein
de barrières entre la radioactivité et
l'environnement
la première barrière c'est la gaine dans
laquelle se trouve le combustible
l'uranium essentiellement
la deuxième c'est la cuve autour du
réacteur
et puis ensuite vous avez ces fameux
dôme de confinement en béton
précontraint la plupart du temps presque
un mètre d'épaisseur de manière à éviter
que les rejets même s'il y a une un
début de fusion quoi que des rejets
gazeux radioactifs puis sortir dans
l'environnement encore une fois j'ai
regardé les chiffres
selon des chercheurs de l'Université
Columbia le charbon tue en moyenne 29
personnes pour chaque térawater
d'électricité produit
le gaz 3
et le nucléaire 0,07
les centrales au charbon et au gaz
relâchent des particules fines et
d'autres polluants dans l'atmosphère
elle cause des maladies
cardiovasculaires des cancers et des
troubles respiratoires
c'est moins spectaculaire qu'un accident
nucléaire mais c'est plus meurtrier
[Musique]
je suis allée à Boston pour rencontrer
des experts comme Matthew bonne
spécialiste des questions d'énergie et
de sécurité à l'Université Harvard
[Musique]
cause très peu de mort par kilowattheure
mais ce n'est pas comme ça qu'il faut
regarder les choses
au Japon il y a pratiquement pas eu de
mort mais la société a été bouleversée
des centaines de milliers de personnes
ont dû quitter leur maison leur travail
quand on ne compte que les morts on
passe à côté de la question
contraire
géologue la nucléaire
du nucléaire aux États-Unis
[Musique]
nucléaire mais on doit bien l'encadrer
dans certains pays il y a des pays
laxistes
je ne vais pas donner de nom
nucléaire se développe en Chine en Inde
en Russie en Corée du Sud
est-ce qu'on peut faire confiance à
leurs autorités de sûreté nucléaire je
ne sais pas
mais pour Mathieu bonnet
le plus gros obstacle à l'énergie
nucléaire ce ne sont pas les risques
d'accidents ce sont les coûts
construites récemment aux États-Unis et
en Europe ont connu des retards énormes
et des dépassements de coûts faramineux
des milliards de dollars dans l'état de
la Géorgie aux États-Unis deux réacteurs
sont en construction depuis 2009 mais
ils ne sont toujours pas en service
le projet devait coûter 15 milliards de
dollars américains il coûtera finalement
plus de 30 milliards
à Flamanville dans le nord-ouest de la
France un réacteur de nouvelles
génération est en construction depuis
2007 il devait démarrer en 2012 on part
maintenant de 2024
le projet devait coûter 3,3 milliards
d'euros
en réalité la facture devrait s'élever à
19,1 milliard c'est 6 fois plus
bonjour Emmanuel c'est Dominique de
Radio-Canada
j'ai voulu revoir Emmanuel Galichet pour
discuter des dérapages dans la
construction de nouveaux réacteurs cette
fois elle m'a donné rendez-vous au CNAM
à Paris Flamanville effectivement on
peut dire que c'est un fiasco faut
appeler les choses par leur nom il y a
plusieurs il y a plusieurs raisons à
cela la première c'est qu'ils sont
partis trop vite et le design n'était
pas totalement établie pour Emmanuel
Galichet c'est l'écoute construction
réacteurs nucléaires explose et que les
problèmes se multiplient c'est parce que
les pays occidentaux ont cessé de former
des scientifiques et des techniciens
spécialisés
elle s'inquiète plus des pertes
économiques entraînées par la fermeture
prématurée de réacteurs en opération
franchement je trouve ça complètement
fou d'avoir des exploitations qui sont
rentables qui n'ont pas de problème de
sûreté et de les fermer aujourd'hui sous
prétexte que on est anti-nucléaire c'est
complètement c'est fou
[Musique]
Emmanuel Galichet n'est pas contre
l'énergie solaire ou éolienne mais elle
croit que dans le contexte des
changements climatiques toutes les
sources d'énergie bas carbone seront
nécessaires
on a passé les dernières années les 50
dernières années vraiment très
tranquille on a eu une vie
extraordinaire nos parents ont une vie
extraordinaire on a eu beaucoup
d'énergie pas cher etc et on est en
train de laisser un monde pour nos
enfants qui est qui est pas très jolie
quand même donc moi j'ai trois enfants
et j'ai envie de faire partie de quelque
chose qui permette que le monde soit
meilleur demain
[Musique]
début février j'atterris à elle qui la
capitale de la Finlande
c'est une ville d'Europe à seulement
deux heures de voiture de la frontière
russe
si je suis ici c'est parce qu'en
Finlande la pluie à l'énergie nucléaire
atteint des sommets jamais vus
à quelques minutes du centre-ville je
retrouve Theater ma naine une militante
pronucléaire
la Finlande et les pays du Nord en
général se réchauffent plus vite que la
moyenne on voit les conséquences des
changements climatiques ici plus
qu'ailleurs
[Musique]
Téa thoraden et biologiste de formation
elle a étudié les loups et les orques
les hivers raccourcissent en Finlande
comme vous voyez il n'y a plus beaucoup
de neige en forêt
en ski sur la neige artificielle
c'est très triste j'adore l'hiver ça
fait partie de notre culture
elle travaille pour l'organisation
environnementale
c'est une ONG qui cherche à préserver la
nature et à stabiliser le climat sans
compromettre le développement humain
[Musique]
j'ai toujours voulu sauver la planète
quand j'étais enfant j'étais inquiète
pour la forêt tropicale et la couche
d'ozone
j'aime le plein air l'hiver et le ski
donc maintenant je me bats pour sauver
l'hiver
elle s'implique maintenant au sein de la
ligue verte le Parti vert finlandais
comme partout en Europe le Parti vert de
Finlande a construit son identité autour
de la résistance au nucléaires mais en
2022 le parti a changé son fusil
d'épaule
il a pris position en faveur de
l'énergie atomique
quand les rapports du GIEC ont commencé
à sortir les gens ont réalisé qu'il y
avait urgence
beaucoup de membres du Parti vert se
sont dit qu'il fallait utiliser tous les
outils à notre disposition
la Finlande c'est fixé l'un des
objectifs les plus ambitieux au monde
pour le climat elle vise à devenir
carbonate d'ici 2035
les Finlandais sont de plus en plus
nombreux à penser que le nucléaire doit
faire partie de la solution
selon un sondage mené en avril 2022 60%
de la population serait favorable à
l'énergie nucléaire en 2014 ils étaient
40%
[Applaudissements]
. l'invasion de l'Ukraine par la Russie
a accélérer l'adhésion populaire
[Musique]
la pluie était déjà à un niveau record
avec la guerre les Finlandais ont
réalisé qu'il ne pouvaient pas dépendre
du gaz russe
ce matin
a donné rendez-vous à deux collègues
les jeunes environnementalistes sont en
général plus ouverts à ces idées que les
militants anti-nucléaires de longue date
qu'on a eu tort pendant 30 ans pour les
jeunes c'est plus facile parce qu'on n'a
pas la même histoire
on n'a pas été traumatisé par Tchernobyl
malgré l'enthousiasme de théâtre Hormann
l'industrie nucléaire en Finlande comme
ailleurs dans le monde connaît des
échecs cuisants
la construction du réacteur holkiliotto
3 a débuté en 2005
il doit produire à lui seul près de 14%
de l'électricité en Finlande
il devait commencer à fournir de
l'électricité en 2009
finalement il a été mis en service après
13 années de retard
[Musique]
je suis venu à Roma une petite ville à
une vingtaine de kilomètres où se trouve
la centrale de Kyoto j'ai cette savoir
si les Finlandais ont encore confiance
au nucléaire après tous ses retards
[Musique]
et propriétaire d'un café dans la
vieille ville elle voit la mise en
service du nouveau réacteur d'un bon œil
même s'il s'est fait attendre
mais c'est quelque chose de positif on a
hâte que ça démarre
ça va réduire nos comptes d'électricité
sur la place du marché quelques hommes
prennent leur café
[Musique]
nous on veut plus d'énergie nucléaire
je connais personne qui en a peur
pourtant les problèmes techniques se
succèdent depuis le début
de la microfissure béton poreux
[Musique]
au départ la facture pour un client
était estimée à 3 milliards d'euros le
réacteur aura finalement coûté 11
milliards d'euros
[Musique]
à côté de la centrale de le kilioto on
trouve un lieu unique au monde que j'ai
très hâte de visiter
c'est ankalo un mot finnois qui signifie
caverne
donc on est rendu à quel profondeur
maintenant Thomas
en calot c'est un tombeau nucléaire
destiné à recevoir des déchets hautement
radioactifs le combustible usé qui
provient des deux centrales nucléaires
du pays
c'est un dépôt souterrain creusé dans le
rock à 450 mètres de profondeur
le géologue Thomas Perret m'entraîne
dans les tunnels du labyrinthe
souterrain
on va creuser environ 40 puits dans ce
tunnel
on va aller creuser de façon à les
espacer de plusieurs mètres les uns des
autres
lorsque le site sera en service à partir
de 2025 normalement les déchets
nucléaires arriveront ici encapsuli dans
un sarcophage un double cylindre d'acier
et de cuivre
tout le procédé sera automatisé on veut
éviter le plus possible que des humains
entre en contact avec la radiation
chaque capsule est transférée à bord
d'un véhicule opéré à distance puis elle
est conduite vers l'un des tunnels pour
être déposé dans un puits creusé dans le
rock
chaque appui est affiché avec de la
betonite un type d'argile qui doit
empêcher l'eau d'entrer en contact avec
la capsule
une fois tous les trous remplis le
tunnel est refermé avec de l'argile puis
sceller avec du béton
la radioactivité du combustible usé
s'atténue progressivement sur de très
longues périodes en calot doit protéger
les déchets pour au moins 100 000 ans
ça fait combien de temps que la roche
s'est formée ici
elle s'est cristallisée il y a environ
un milliard 800 ou 1 milliard 900
millions d'années
[Musique]
Thomas Perret a beau être convaincant
l'échelle de temps me donne un peu le
vertige
jamais dans l'histoire l'être humain n'a
construit une structure censée résister
pendant 100 000 ans il y a seulement 20
000 ans après tout une calotte de glace
plusieurs kilomètres d'épaisseur
recouvraient le Québec
lors de la prochaine période glaciaire
le glacier ne déplacera pas les capsules
elles sont placées trop profondément
dans le rock elle ne pourront donc pas
être impactées
le cuivre qui recouvre les capsules et
censés résister à la corrosion
selon les calculs du constructeur même
si des éléments radioactifs venaient à
s'échapper il leur faudrait des milliers
d'années pour traverser le rock
même s'il y avait un tout petit trou
dans la capsule
l'impact des éléments radioactifs serait
devenu inoffensif pour les humains et
l'environnement une fois rendu à la
surface le niveau de radiation serait
inférieur à celui qu'on retrouve
naturellement dans l'environnement
au fond ce qui m'impressionne le plus
avec un calot c'est pas tellement les
prouesses technologiques c'est surtout
le consensus social autour du projet
aux États-Unis dans l'État du Nevada un
projet de stockage géologique profond et
dans l'impasse tellement il suscite de
position
en France on a choisi un site près du
village de bure en 1998 mais le projet
avance à pas de tortue
au Canada le choix du site n'est pas
encore arrêté
[Musique]
j'en ai parlé avec Passy tcho et ma le
porte-parole donne calot
depuis le début
pas juste à propos de l'enfouissement
des déchets mais aussi sur la production
d'énergie nucléaire
plus les gens sont informés moins ils
ont peur
théâtre
finira par s’étendre au reste de
l'Europe en attendant elle a décidé de
quitter la ville
je vais aller plus au nord parce qu'il y
a encore de bons hivers là-bas
[Musique]
j'ai deux enfants qui ont vite et 4 ans
je veux me battre pour leur avenir
[Musique]
salut
son quart de travail à l'urgence
dans un hôpital de Toronto ces journées
il est consacre à militer pour l'énergie
nucléaire
dans une autre vie il a été guide de
canaux et de chasse au yuku
bizarre pour moi vivre ici en Toronto
parce que je suis un Mountain même
comme médecin il a travaillé au sein
d'une communauté autochtone puis dans
une clinique pour travailleur migrants
depuis qu'il a un enfant il s'inquiète
pour l'avenir de la planète
le réchauffement climatique est devenu
son cheval de bataille
[Musique]
en médecine d'urgence on parle souvent
de triage
on veut savoir quel est le problème le
plus urgent le patient le plus malade
pour mettre nos efforts au bon endroit
pour ma génération le problème le plus
urgent ce sont les changements
climatiques
à partir d'un studio dans sa maison il a
mis ma baladeau sur le climat et la
transition énergétique
[Musique]
il participe à des manifestations
comme ici en marge de la conférence des
Nations Unies sur les changements
climatiques à Glasgow en 2021
[Musique]
je ne connais pas de domaine anciences
ou en ingénierie où l'écart est plus
grand entre ce que le public pense
est-ce que les experts disent
l'Apocalypse redoutée par mes parents la
guerre nucléaire était basée sur la
fission atomique aujourd'hui la fission
pourrait sauver ma génération des
changements climatiques
aujourd'hui je retrouve Christy Fura
Ottawa il participe à la conférence de
l'association nucléaire canadienne
il est ici pour rencontrer des acteurs
clés des gouvernements et de l'industrie
le gouvernement fédéral s'intéresse de
plus en plus à l'énergie nucléaire il
faut une vraie collaboration entre le
fédéral les provinces et l'industrie
pour réussir ce Paris dans l'air
d'exposition plusieurs vendeurs de
petits réacteurs modulaires des PRM me
vantent leur technologie
les PRM sont la coqueluche de leur au
sein de l'industrie nucléaire
comme leur nom l'indique les PRM sont
plus petits que les réacteurs
conventionnels
leurs concepteur promettent qu'ils
seront plus sûr plus facile à construire
et plus économique
des tout premier au monde devrait être
construits ici en Ontario sur le site de
la centrale nucléaire de Darlington à
l'est de Toronto on sera les premiers
dans le monde occidental a réussi ce
pari à réussir ses premières réacteurs
c'est vraiment un avenir formidable pour
le Canada grâce à de l'énergie Dominique
minière a dirigé l'ensemble du parc
nucléaire français avant de quitter
Électricité de France pour venir
s'installer ici en 2019
il a pris la tête d'interio
jusqu'à sa retraite en décembre dernier
je cherchais un endroit où on pouvait
faire du nouveau nucléaire j'ai regardé
dans le mot où est-ce qu'on pouvait le
faire et le pays le plus intéressant
pour le faire était le Canada
nucléaires de Darlington de Pickering et
de Bruce au total ce sont 18 des 19
réacteurs nucléaires en opération au
Canada l'autre est au Nouveau-Brunswick
ces réacteurs sont de type Candou une
technologie canadienne
depuis 2016
interviews les quatre réacteurs de la
centrale de Darlington
c'est un projet de plusieurs milliards
de dollars canadiens délivraient dans
les temps et ce budget je suis désolé
mais en matière de projet nucléaire
c'est sans doute un des rares
si l'Ontario tire si bien son épingle du
jeu selon Dominique minière c'est parce
qu'elle n'a jamais tourné le dos
nucléaire
[Musique]
la technologie Kondo a été rachetée en
2011 par SNC-Lavalin j'ai visité leurs
installations en banlieue de Toronto où
ils forment leur travailleur alors on
est essentiellement en train de rebassir
les canaux à neuf c'est presque aussi
complexe que de bâtir quelque chose de
neuf
Marcotte le vice-président au
développement des affaires
entreprises pourraient construire de
nouveaux réacteurs kandous au Canada ou
à l'étranger
je parle avec le gouvernement de la
Roumanie par exemple ils ont à 4000 MW
de charbon encore qui brûle à tous les
jours on parle avec eux il faut
absolument arrêter ça pouvez-vous nous
aider oui absolument alors c'est pour ça
qu'ils vont être construire deux autres
en Ontario le petit réacteur nucléaire
qui sera construit sur le site
Darlington ne sera pas de type Cando
intério
a choisi Ji Itachi pour sa conception
elle espère commencer la construction en
2025 le réacteur de l'Ontario est censé
servir de modèle pour la Saskatchewan
l'Alberta et le Nouveau-Brunswick qui
mis sur les petits réacteurs pour
décarboner leurs production électrique
je dis pas que c'est du plug and play
mais quand même c'est pas loin mais pour
l'instant les petits réacteurs n'ont pas
encore fait leurs preuves
Dominique Mignières admet que ce sont en
quelque sorte les réacteurs de la
dernière chance
on trouvera personne pour soutenir le
nouveau nucléaire si on n'a pas des
succès
les militants pro nucléaires que j'ai
rencontrés sont convaincant
[Musique]
avait lancé une pétition contre la
fermeture de la centrale de Pickering en
Ontario qui devait fermer en 2025
le gouvernement de l'Ontario envisage
maintenant de remettre la centrale à
neuf
quand vous mettez un enfant au monde
vous regardez 80 ans en avant si les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre vous
inquiète il n'y a rien de plus puissant
que vous puissiez faire que d'empêcher
la fermeture d'une centrale nucléaire
pour devenir carbone neutre d'ici 2050
les experts estiment qu'il va falloir
doubler voire tripler la production
d'électricité sur terre
il faut électrifier les transports le
chauffage et les procédés industriels
qui dépendent des combustibles fossiles
ça fait beaucoup d'électricité à
produire
[Musique]
en Belgique les militants chantent et
Marjane contrairement à John Lennon il
n'aurait pas d'un monde détaché des
besoins matériels
il rêve d'un monde sans émission de gaz
à effet de serre
le gouvernement belge les a entendus il
envisage maintenant de prolonger la
durée de vie de trois réacteurs
pour réussir son retour en grâce
l'énergie nucléaire devra être bien
encadrée et socialement accepté
à ces conditions à long terme elle
pourrait faire partie de la solution
[Musique]